はい、ここからは皆さんが作るAIエージェントのパフォーマンスというのを最大限にするための非常に強力なテクニック、サブエージェントという概念について学んでいきたいと思います。
サブエージェントというのは、メインエージェントの下にそれぞれの専門分野を担当するサブエージェントを配置する、みたいな考え方のことです。
例えば会社で優秀なマネージャーにリサーチ担当の部下とか、メール作成担当の部下とか、データ分析担当の部下が配置されるみたいな感じで、
各々特化した部下がいて、AI同士のチームを組むみたいな感じですね。
専門家を一人ずつ作るみたいな感じです。
なんでこのサブエージェントっていうのが必要になるかというと、AIに複雑なタスクをさせようとすると、一つのAI、メインエージェントですね、これにあれもこれもと指示を詰め込むことになってしまい、
このAIエージェント自体が混乱しやすかったりとか 出力が安定しないエラーばっか出てきてしまう可能性というのが高くなりますよと
安定した出力結果を目的とする場合より複雑なシステムメッセージですね が必要になってしまうためコストがかさむこともありますよと
そのためサブエージェントというのを作る必要があるんですけども このサブエージェントを構成する方法を大きく分けて2つあります
このメインエージェントこれがメインエージェントだとしてと同じキャンバス内 このワークフロー内にサブエージェントも全部追加する感じですね
イメージとしてはこんなのが2つこんな感じであって これがサブこれがメインですよみたいな感じ
でやる っていう方法が一つあるのともう一つはメインエージェントとは全く別のワークフロー
別のキャンバスにサブエージェントをそれぞれ作って それを接続する方法ですね
どちらも可能なんですけどもこの講座では校舎別キャンバスにワークフローを作るよっていうのを ベストプラクティスとして推奨しますのでそれを進めていきたいとおもいます
なんでこう別のワークフローにサブエージェントを作るといいかというと大きなメリットが ございます
エージェントごとにキャンバスを完全に分けてしまうことで、機能の追加とか修正がそれぞれしやすくなったりとか、どこで問題が起きたかっていうのも特定しやすくなる。
エラーハンドリングというのがしやすくなるからなんですね。
この1個のワークフローに何もかもをつなげてしまうと、どこでエラーが起きていて、どこを修正すればいいかというのがちょっと分かりにくくなってしまうんですけども、
これを全く別のキャンバスにワークフローを組み立てることによって、このキャンバスのこのノードでエラーが起きているんだなというのが分かりやすくなりますよというところです。
ではですね、早速、リサーチを専門に担当するサブのエージェントというのを別のキャンバスに作成していきたいと思います。
このメインのデモというキャンバスはそのままにして、一旦ダッシュボードに戻ります。
このダッシュボードですね。戻ったら新しく右上からCreate Workflowを押して、この一番最初の画面を出します。
名前は、例えばサブエージェントの、こんな感じ。サブエージェントのサーチ用、リサーチ担当のサブエージェントみたいな感じでやります。
では最初のメインのエージェントを作ったときと同じように、まずはトリガーの設定ですね。
このトリガーの設定、サブエージェントにおいてはメインエージェント、マネージャーみたいなメインのエージェントから呼び出されて動く部下の動きをしないといけないんですね。
そのためまずキャンバス開いて検索ここですねで これを検索してみてください
するとこんな感じでサブワークフローを動き出すための トリガーというのが出てきます
これですね これを押すとこんな感じでトリガーが置かれますよと
これが他のワークフローから実行されたとき、呼び出されたとき、このワークフローを動かし始めますよというみたいなトリガーになります。
このトリガーノードの設定画面でですね、このデータモードとかあるんですけども、ここをこのAll Dataというのにしてください。
こうすることでメインエージェントから渡された指示、データっていうのをすべて受け取れるようになりますよと。
はい、なのでトリガーが設定できたら、次ですね、この部下の頭脳のところを追加します。
トリガーのプラスから押して、メインの方でもやったAIエージェントですね、を追加します。
ここは本当メインと同じようにChat ModelはOpenRouterっていうのをやってもこれですねこれを
やってここを見てみるとCredentialの下の部分に
先ほど設定した認証情報っていうのが選択できるようになっているんですね こんな感じで一度Credential認証情報というのを登録してしまえば
別のワークフロー、全く別のワークフローでも簡単にそれを引き継ぐことができるので、非常に便利な機能になります。
さて、このサブエージェントっていうのは、ここにも書いてあるようにリサーチ担当になります。
前回のパートでメインエージェントが使っていたTavily、
HTTPリクエストでTavilyというのを使っていたと思うんですけども、この検索機能っていうのをこちらのサブエージェントに移植、お引越しさせましょう。
どうやるかというと、まず一旦Saveして、先ほどのキャンバスですね、戻っていただくと、このHTTPリクエストでTavilyのものがあったと思うので、これをコピーします。
こんな感じでクリップボードにコピーされましたよとなったら、ダッシュボード戻ってサブエージェント、サーチ用のサブエージェントに戻って、コントロールVとかコマンドVを押すと、こんな感じで簡単に移植ができてしまいます。
貼り付けたHTTPリクエストのノードっていうのを、サブエージェントのAIエージェントの右側にあるこのツールですね、と接続をします。
こんな感じで、これでこのサブエージェント、もう本当シンプルなワークフローになっているんですけども、
このエージェントは、HTTPリクエスト、Tavilyという検索ツールだけを持った検索特化型のAIエージェントを作ることができました。
これは検索だけをやってくれるワークフローになります。
では、このワークフロー、サブエージェントというのが正しく動くかテストしたいなと思うところだと思うんですけども、少しお待ちください。
このサブエージェントの最初のトリガーは、他のワークフローから呼び出されることで起動するものでしたよね。
つまり、このワークフロー単体でこの実行を押しても、そもそもですね、
呼び出す親、マネージャーがいないためテスト実行ができません。
そこで、一度このノードを、このワークフローを動かしたいなと思ったら、まずはお試しデータみたいなのをトリガーに設定することができますよと。
画面の右側に、こういったアウトプットのところが出てきます。
この先ほどの右上にある鉛筆マークですね。鉛筆マークを押すとこんな感じでコードを書く場所があるので、今回はこんな感じで書きたいと思います。
1という数字をアウトプットしますという設定ですね。
これが入力できたら右上Saveを押してしっかりピン止めですね。されているかどうかっていうのを確認しましょう。
これはオレンジ色になってたらピン止めされているというところになるのでこれを押します。
これでこのサブエージェントをテスト実行する際はこの常に1というデータが流れてくるようになりましたよというところですね。
次に、これが設定できたら、AIエージェントの設定に入ります。
AI Agentノードを開くと、まず確認するところで、左側のインプットにクエリ1という感じで、先ほど設定した1というデータがここに表示されています。
これをAIエージェントにも入れたいので、まずはここのSource for Prompt (User Message)のところをこっちの下の部分を押すと、プロンプトが決められます。
入力できる部分が決められます。
これが出たら、ここのクエリというのを引っ張ってきてここに載せると、しっかり1という数字が入力されますよという感じになります。
これで最初のこのトリガーですね。設定した1というデータをAIエージェントのプロンプトとして受け取れるようになりました。
これが設定できたら、このAIエージェントの実行をしてみると、しっかりと1というのがアウトプットされているのがわかるかなと思います。
エラーが出ずにしっかりと実行されていると正解になるので、ここが緑色になっているのを確認できたら、最後にこのAIエージェント、この部下の部分ですね、にその役割をしっかり認識させるためのシステムメッセージですね、前回のパートでもお伝えしてあるシステムメッセージを追加します。
Add Optionからシステムメッセージを押して、ここの部分にこのようなプロンプトを書きます。
こんな感じでシステムメッセージはあなたは優秀なリサーチャーです。 ユーザーから受け取ったメッセージの内容をあなたが持っている
HTTPリクエストのツールを使ってリサーチをして、その結果だけを回答してくださいという風にプロンプトを決めます。
このようにサブエージェントの役割というのをしっかりと明示、明確に指示してあげましょう。
これができたら、Saveを押します。
ここまでできたら、いよいよメインのエージェントとサブエージェントを連携させる手順に入っていきたいと思います。
まずはメインエージェントのワークフローに戻ります。 先ほどのメインで使っていたもの。
まずはこのメインのここの部分ですね。サブエージェントに移植しちゃっているので、このノードはメインエージェントのAIエージェントから消します。削除しちゃって大丈夫です。
次にこのメインエージェントのAI Agentノードに新しいツールを追加します。
ここを押していただいて、ここですね。call n8nワークフローツールというのがあるので、これをクリックします。
するとこんな感じのマークのツールがしっかりとAIエージェントに接続されていると思うので、これを確認したら
このノードですね、開いていただいて、ここに
先ほど作成したサブエージェントのワークフローを選択したいと思います。
これ開くとこんな感じで自分が作ったワークフローが出てくるので、先ほどのこのサブエージェントサーチというのをしっかりと選ぶようにしましょう。
これでこのワークフローですね。この全体のワークフローは
サブエージェントサーチという部下を呼び出すツールになりました このチャットで送ることでそのチャットの文章を理解してサブエージェントに送ってそしたら
サブエージェントが起動するみたいなイメージですね 最後にですねこのメインエージェントの
ここの部分ですねシステムメッセージを修正して新しく入った部下 サブエージェントツールですねのことを教えてあげます
こんな感じであなたにサブエージェントサーチというリサーチが得意な部下がいます ユーザーから何かしら調べてほしいと依頼された場合
必ずこのサブエージェントサーチツールを使ってリサーチを実行してくださいというふうにプロンプトを置いておきます。
それができたらしっかりとSaveを押してこのメインエージェントを完成させます。
これをしたことによってこのメインエージェントとサブエージェントの連携ができるようになりました。
サブエージェント側で一つ修正が必要です。
何かというと、このサブエージェントを戻ってみると、トリガーの部分に先ほど1というデータだけを使ってくださいという設定をしてしまいました。
テスト用のデータで作っているものなので、ピンを一旦外します。
それができたら、Saveを押して保存をしておきます。 このようにサブエージェントとメインエージェントの設定ができたら、
このチャット欄に何か質問を調べてほしいことを書きます。
例えば、織田信長について調べて教えてくださいというふうにメッセージを送ると、このような感じで織田信長は日本の戦国時代の何々というのが出てきます。
このメインエージェント自体にはリサーチをしてくれるノードっていうのはないんですけども、この
コールサブエージェントサーチという別のサブエージェントを呼び出してそっちでリサーチをしてリサーチしたものをこっちがまた受け取って
このChat Modelがそれを判断しておく、ここに書き出すみたいな感じで、このメインエージェントにサーチ機能がなくてもサブエージェントをつなげていけば、つなげておけば、しっかりメインエージェントでも検索した結果を出すことができるよというところですね。
はい、このような感じで、今回は最初から別キャンバスにサブエージェントというのを作るベストプラクティスというのを実践しました。
このサブエージェントですね。
もしですね、皆さんが最初メインエージェントと同じキャンバスにサブエージェントの機能を作ってしまっていたとしても心配はいりません。
このサブエージェントのノード群をコピーして、別のワークフローを新しく作ってお引越しすることで、メインエージェントを動かしてもしっかり呼び出すことができます。
このようにメインのエージェントとサブのエージェントを明確に区分けすることで、非常に管理しやすく、強力なAIエージェントの仕組みを作成することができました。